Mike Ward en fin de semaine a
dit : j'ai offert à la ville de
Montréal des abris polyvalents
pour que les sans-abri puissent
aller se réchauffer. Des mini
maisons si vous voulez. Elle
avait n'a toujours pas répondu à
mon offre. Ça fait deux fois.
Anie Samson et Luc Ferrandez,
bonsoir. On va écouter la
mairesse d'abord tu répond
pourquoi elle a dit non et o
revient ensuite.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- J'ai envie de vous dire que,
ni la ville, ni les organismes
communautaires qui travaillent
avec les personnes en situation
d'itinérance, là, on aime ça
dire "non" quand on nous offre
de l'aide. Il y a personne qperi
aime ça dire "non". Mais, ce
qu'il faut comprendre, c'est
qu'en ce moment, à Montréal,
puis moi, je peux pas parler
des autres municipalités, mais
à Montréal, le problème, c'est
l'espace, c'est d'avoir
du personnel qualifié, des gens
qui peuvent accompagner
les personnes en situation
d'itinérance.
- S'en est suivi le refus de la
r Twitter, sur Facebook.
Beaucoup de gens ont dit :
pourquoi la ville de Montréal
refuse drefuse drefuse drefuse ,
qu'en pensez-vous?
- Je trouve ça plate Mme Plante
et du non l'année dernière et
cette année. Je pense que ça
mérite d'être bien étudié. Il
faut l'expliquer. Oui, on a
besoin d'endroit parce qu'il y a
des gens... on l'a dit cette
semaine, il y a des itinérants
qui ne veulent pas aller àl'ints
dorment dehors. Il y en a quatre
qui sont morts de froid depuis
le début de l'année. Pour moi,
c'est important des heures :
regardons l'ensemble, faites un
projet pilote avec un organisme
qui va dire oui, avec un support
qui va avec, bien Est-
ce que le feu, c'est propre
fils? Comment c'est fait? Dire
non tout simplement bêtement
sans les avoir vu, je trouve ça
plate parce que des projets
pilotent, c'est ce qui nous fait
avancer. On peut l'essayer. Si
ça ne marche pas,
mérite de dire : oui on a
essayé, non ça ne marche pas. Il
faut premps de bien
regarder le dossier.
- Je vais revenir avec des
questions sur ce que ça veut
dire encadrer. Lyu première
question?
- Je disais tout à l'heure que
par exemple, les toilettespublie
commencer en 2017, on s'est
rendu compte que des toilettes
sans supervision, c'est un échec
total. Il faut comprendre que
les gens qui sont dans la rue
souffrent souvent de problèmes
de santé mentale. Ça se p
pauvre dans la rue : des gens
qui font de la taxation, de
l'intimidation, de la
prostitution, de l'injection de
drogue, il y a de tout dans les
toilettes publiques. On n'en est
arrivé à la conclusion que
laisser une toilette sans
surveillance, ce n'est pas faire
un cadeau aux itinérants. Même
chose avec les églises. Avant,
on ouvraurés
qui ouvraient les églises. Vous
remarquerez que la plupart des
curés qui sont pourtant des gens
bien int
décidés de fermer leurs églises
parce que c'est pas ses mille et
une chose. Les églises dans mon
quartier voir les voir les voirs
curés et je leur demandais
pourquoi il n'était pas ouvert.
Il me racontait des histoires
extraordinairement surprenantes
comme par exemple des gens qui
faisaient leurs besoins sur des
bancs d'église parce que c'était
trop intoxiqué pour se rendre
te mettre un
espace, qui va y avoir droit?
Est-ce qu'elle a personne la
plus forte va dire : moi j'y
vais et toi tu t'en vas.
- Vous êtes que c'est une fausse
bonne idée?
- Oui.- Comment vous gérez une e
de même? Ça prend du monde pour
gérer les cabanes.
- On avait des organismes entre
autres aujourd'hui qui on dit :
moi, je suis capable de lesgérer
année, c'est dans le temps où il
fait froid et/ou actuellement il
y a encore des gens qui vont
dormir dehors ce soir. Il y a 20
cabanes, il y a 20
vont être suivies, qui vont
accepter un protocole en disant
: tu coches là, mais tu ne fais
pas rien brûler.
l'encadrer. Un projet pilote, si
on ne laissait pas, on aura
jamais la réponse. On a bien
posé et c'est vrai que la ville
est faite de fonctionnaires et
on va jamais dans un chemin
qu'on ne connaît pas trop. On
est comme ça nous autres les
Québécoi
n'est pas sûr, on n'ira pas
parce qu'on connaît pas. Mais
pourquoi pas l'essayer? J'ai
essayé plein de choses dans ma
vie. Des fois ça a bien
fonctionné et des fois ça n'a
ait
pas, on n'aura pas le mérite de
les.
- Luc, pourquoi on essaye pas?
- Je pense que la probabilité
que ça ne marche pas et forte.
pourrait
servir à une certaine clientèle
par contre. Il y a des gens qui
ne veulent pas aller dans les
centres. Il y en a un qui est
mort au grand dam de la falaise,
il refusait de regagner un
centre. Pour ces personnes, dans
les soirées où il fait
extrêmement froid, ce n'était
pas de cibler ces personnes et
de les donner à, ça pourrait
être fait, il faudrait que ce
soit encadré.- Je ne - Je ne - t
des itinérants à Victoriaville.
La mère a envie de payer, tant
mieux. L'essayer sur des
clientèle est particulière. Ce
convoi le soir, les polices
envoient. On est avec un
organisme communautaire qui dit
: moi je m'engage
que ce soit bien utilisé. Quoi
pas l'essayer? Ça coûte rien,
c'est gratuit. À par
l'organisme.
- Pourquoi pas l'essayer mais en
prenant quand même des indices
de ce qui s'est passé avant?
Dans les
avait des espèces de tuyaux de
béton qui servait de tunnel où
les enfants pouvaient passer. On
les a tous enlevés. Pourquoi?
Parce qu
faisaient leurs besoins dedans.
Les enfants étaient mis en
contact avec des déjections
humaines. C'est ça la réalité.
- Il faut revenir avec des
gardiens de parc.
- On pourrait peut-être allere s
toilettes publiques, maisdes dis
avec nos amis européens ou
américains qui ont des toilettes
publiques dans toutes les
grandes villes? Il les garde, et
légère. Il peut arriver des
incidents, on les enlève toutes.
- C'est une question
d'investissement. Il faut mettre
du personnel pour s'en occuper.
Il faut faire le choix de mettre
- Et les personnels, c'est de
l'argent. Merci.
Je lance un message à des gens
qui auraient beaucoup d'argent
et qui va l'aider.
Pour donner aux organismes
qui aident les sans-abri :
- Mission Old Brewery :
donnez.missionoldbrewery.ca,
514 788-1884.
- Mission Bon Accueil :
montrealaidemontreal.com
- Maison du Père :
fondation.maisondupere.org,
514 845-0168.